new reports show that the coronavirus
vaccine may be causing
inflammation of the heart myocarditis
in some teens and young adults teens and
young adults
who face statistically very very very
little risk from the virus itself
this is not some kooky conspiracy theory
or some unsubstantiated meme
floating around the internet this is
according to a report from the cdc's
advisory committee
on immunization practices rand paul gets
dr fauci to change his
story again on wuhan institute funding
an anti-cop radio host kills a cop
and democrat senator tammy duckworth
spills crocodile tears
over the republican threat to our
democracy
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from clint beastwood
it's a great it's a great name they
aren't afraid of the nra they are afraid
of
we the people being armed this is true
you know that the nra
is the largest i guess oldest
gun lobby in america and the way the
left always tries to
to attack the nra as they say it's the
gun manufacturer's lobby
it's just the gun makers
screwing over those dumb rubes like all
you deplorable irredeemables out there
i am a lifetime member of the nra i know
many of you are members of the nra the
nra sure
in some ways it represents the interests
of the gun makers but the gun makers are
there because we keep buying all the
guns so who are they really speaking for
we the people who cherish our second
amendment rights
one of those one of those very important
very american ways
to defend our other rights especially in
times of chaos and craziness
one great way to defend yourself in
times of chaos and craziness
invest in physical precious metals such
as acre gold
you want to buy gold bars but you don't
necessarily have all the cash at once to
buy gold bars gold bars are not
you know they cost a little bit of money
don't they what if i told you you could
invest in gold bars for as little as 30
a month
michael you would say you're crazy
that's impossible gold costs more than
that
acre gold has figured out an ingenious
way
you send acre gold 30 bucks a month you
invest in your gold stash when when the
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house acre has a new 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar they've got lots of great products
that will help you get started investing
in physical
gold i have really enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals
great way also to hedge when things
start to get a little crazy in the
economy
head on over head on over to
getacregold.com
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that is getacre gold.com
knowles thank you acre gold for
supporting the show
if i had told you yesterday on this show
that there are reports that in some
cases i'm not saying it's a lot of cases
but in some cases
the vaccine is causing inflammation of
the heart
in otherwise healthy teenagers young
adults
i i probably would have been kicked off
of youtube and frankly i may well be
kicked off of youtube for saying it
today
but today it's a lot harder for them to
kick me off of youtube because
the cdc is acknowledging that this is a
problem
and they're investigating it all of
which is to say you know how much
i i hate to mention that i told you so
but i suppose i i will do it here
the argument for vaccine hesitancy
among young healthy people
doesn't require the science or the
studies
or the investigation or the cdc
it's a very simple calculation we've had
a virus now for about 18 months
a virus that almost certainly leaks from
the wuhan laboratory we'll get to that
in just one second
we have a virus that has been around for
about 18 months now
we know a little bit about it i'm not
even saying we know a ton about it but
we generally know what coronaviruses are
we know a little bit about it
and we know with this virus just because
of our year and a half of experience
with it
that young people are at statistically
virtually no risk whatsoever
right we have a vaccine that's been
around for what about
seven months now and we don't know very
much about it
and it was developed very hastily and it
uses
sort of vaccine technology that we have
not seen used widely
very much before and so if i'm a young
healthy person
i'm going to take those two factors into
consideration
and i'm going to make a prudent judgment
i'm not saying i'll never get the
vaccine but
conservatives generally speaking would
prefer the devil we sort of know
to the devil that we definitely don't
know right it's a very basic judgment
and then every time one of these stories
comes out they say well but it's very
rare the blood clotting in the women
it's very rare well the myocarditis
in men is very rare okay i don't care
how rare it is
what's the rarity of otherwise healthy
young people dying of the coronavirus
without comorbidities it's that then
it's truly basically zero
and even with comorbidities it's still
pretty rare
you're not allowed to use this kind of
judgment you're not allowed
to use prudence you're not allowed to
use your own common sense
it's the it's the issue of the wuhan lab
anybody with two brain cells to rub
together
knew that it was very likely that this
virus had something to do with the lab
that was studying these sorts of viruses
that 400 yards away from the wuhan wet
market where the thing allegedly began
but when we said this when we just used
our common sense a year ago we were told
the fake news there were facts there
were actual fact
checks fact checks that now have had to
be changed i guess the facts are
changing too the facts didn't change
it's it's the permission of what sort of
facts we're allowed to say
and even dr fauci the expert himself the
exalted one dr fauci
is admitting sort of you know it's very
clever with his language he's admitting
sort of
that he got a very important thing wrong
do you remember what was it a week or
two ago
when rand paul excuse me dr rand paul
a u.s senator was grilling dr fauci and
he said hey dr fauci
do you regret that the nih was funding
gain of function research that was
associated
with the wuhan institute dr fauci
totally denied it
dr fauci do you still support funding of
the
nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled
entirely and completely incorrect
that the nih has not ever and does not
now
fund gain of function research
in the find wuhan barrick
we do not fund do you find dr barrick's
gain of function research
dr barrett does not doing gain to
function research and if it is
it's according to the guidelines and it
is being conducted in north
carolina dr barrick
does this this is a direct quote dr
barrick
does not doing gain of function research
and if it is it's totally whatever right
that last the last few words there
was not a direct quote but that was the
gist of it
you can tell he's getting tripped up on
this you can tell he doesn't like that
rand paul is pushing this
because of how tripped up he gets on the
grammar dr barrick does
not doing gain and function research but
if
it is it's happening in north carolina
so even the words are messed up and the
structure is ridiculous
what you're suggesting is just not
happening but also if it is it's
totally fine well what is it man you
can't say it's definitely not happening
but also if it is it's totally fine
because he knows that rand paul is
catching him here what is gain of
function research everyone's using this
fancy term
just means you beef up natural viruses
you humans go in you beef up natural
viruses
and then sometimes they escape the wuhan
lab
so he was denying this a week or two ago
yesterday republican senator john
kennedy was grilling him
and dr fauci he leaves a little more
wiggle room because he doesn't want to
be perjuring himself before the senate
how do you know they didn't lie to you
excuse me sir
how do you know they didn't lie to you
and use the money for gain of function
research anyway
well we've seen the results of the
experiments that were done
and that were published and that the
viruses that they
um uh studied are on
public databases now so none of that was
gain of functions so
how do you know they didn't do the
research and
not put it on their website there's no
way of
guaranteeing that but in our experience
with grantees including chinese grantees
which we've had interactions with for a
very long period of time
they're very competent trustworthy
scientists i'm not talking about
anything else in china i'm talking about
the scientists
that you would expect that they would
abide by the conditions of the grant
which they've done for the years that
we've had interactions so you don't
think the chinese would lie to you
you know kennedy is great because he's a
very
intelligent guy but he plays this really
down home like so
hold on you're telling me that uh they
are doing this sort of thing
or they may be doing this sort of thing
wuhan and your only assurance that
they're not is
their word for is that it well yes the
chinese would totally never lie to us
i'm very smart i'm dr fauci and i
totally believe
the chinese communist government but no
actually what fauci says is
no i believe the scientists you see i
don't know about the government
okay but i believe the scientists
that the scientists are the government
the scientists are controlled by the
government it's china
china and it's it's government research
too it's not
no they're totally above board no
they're not
they're not and they hid this for months
and months and months i actually have a
sneaking suspicion this is a slight
digression
i suspect that dr fauci has heard my
impression of him
because i've noticed in recent days i
don't want to flatter myself or anything
but in recent days he's been trying to
tamp down his brooklyn accent
but i i he's not fooling anybody okay
i just wonder i don't know i don't have
evidence for it's just my common sense
all right
i know you're not allowed to use that
sofauchi says
he can't guarantee that the money that
the united states taxpayers
under his watch sent to
the wuhan institute he can't guarantee
that it wasn't used
for the sort of research that we know
that the wuhan institute was engaged in
and which
very likely was the cause of shutting
down the world for the past year
okay so now rand paul comes out there
rand paul who's really done a great just
as a political mover he's done a great
job of setting himself up as the foil to
dr fatchi
he proposed a ban full ban on gain of
function research in china
on the floor of the senate yesterday
received
applause and an ovation we may never
know whether the pandemic arose from the
lab in wuhan
but we do know that so far no
intermediate animal host has been
discovered
thousands of animals at the wet market
have been looked at none of them have
carried covid19
we've tried to infect covet 19 into bats
it doesn't grow well in bats it seems
most adapted
and suitable for humans we may not know
whether this ever arose out of a wuhan
lab
but i think gain of function research
where we take a deadly virus sometimes
much more deadly than kovid
and then we increase its
transmissibility to mammals is wrong
in 2014 nih stopped all of this research
i'm using the same definition to say any
gain of function research should not be
funded in china
with u.s taxpayer dollars and i
recommend a yes vote thank you
all those in favor say hi opposed nay
it seems as if the eyes have it
the amendment is agreed to
cheers do you hear that of course the
eyes have it
what i don't care how radical a senator
you are i don't care who pro-china you
are you're not going to say you know i
think we should keep
allowing the chinese i think we should
keep funding the chinese communists
to create and beef up deadly viruses to
shut down the world of course not
so it's a voice vote it goes all for the
eyes and then they cheer afterwards
raises a question though
if everybody's cheering for this sort of
thing everybody is cheering and saying
do not fund the chinese to do this kind
of research
who thought this was a good idea there
were republicans and democrats in that
chamber senators from both parties who
thought
it was a good idea to fund chinese
communists
to beef up deadly viruses to make them
more
transmissible to humans the answer
the geniuses dr fauci all the eggheads
all the geniuses
they thought that was a great idea
rand paul is a very astute politician
clearly a pretty good scientist too but
an astute politician so he goes out and
he says
hey we're going to ban gain of function
research in china everybody cheers him
on
and yet we have been doing this
we have been funding this wuhan
institute of virology
and even dr fauci who's very very
precise with his language he's always
trying to leave himself little outs
even he's saying yeah i guess it's
possible that we funded the gain of
function research and we know because we
were funding
certain doctors that may not have been
doing the research in wuhan but the
research was going to wuhan okay
why are these guys that why are the
people
who think it's a good idea to fund
chinese communists
doing the sort of research that can lead
to these deadly viruses why are they the
ones
who have so much political power who
have so little democratic accountability
why have we enabled them to run our
country because it's progress because
they're the scientists
because they know what's best much
better than people who just have common
sense and prudence
much better than people who are elected
by the people much better
than our representatives right
wrong wrong that's this is a repudiation
of the progressive pretense that the
genius eggheads in the lab coats can run
our lives better than we can
this whole year and a half has been a
repudiation of that
every single democrat in that chamber
that was applauding
and both parties and there are some
there are some
dumb senators in there okay i hate to
put it that bluntly
but there are some people who don't have
a very high iq there are some people who
didn't do very well on their sats who
are in that chamber who are nonetheless
better at governing than dr fauci who i
suspect has a very high iq and probably
did very well in his sats
that's isn't that a very strange fact
about our government now i don't want to
say too many nice things about the
democrat senators
because the democrat senators and
democrat politicians for 100 years are
the ones who have allowed us to get to
this situation
where the egghead idiots are the ones
who have have
made such poor decisions
they pretend that progress
scientific progress all the technocracy
is just an extension of
our democracy rather than a repudiation
of it you hear this kind of thing a lot
a democrat tammy duckworth just came out
and
not on the wuhan point but actually on
on the point of following president
trump and the direction of the gop
she says that republicans would rather
defend trump
than defend our democracy
time and again they've chosen to stand
with donald trump in his lives
and uh time and again when they've been
given the opportunity to do so and when
push comes to shove
they fold and they stand with donald
trump and they have shown that they
would rather choose donald trump
over the truth they would rather defend
traders uh and spread lies
than defend our democracy uh and so i i
you know i i wish i could say i i i was
surprised but i'm not because
they've done this time and again when
they when push comes to shove
they choose donald trump over our
democracy
oh you know tammy duckworth is not
among the brightest bulbs in the senate
pack
she is reciting a usual talking point
it's one of my least favorite slogans in
all of politics i think this one is even
worse
than the country over party line you
know that we uh you need to choose
country over party
and what the only thing that ever really
means is you need to side with the
democrats over the republicans
country over party no you're just
choosing one party over the other party
but this is a similar one this you're
choosing trump over our democracy
what does that mean people support
donald trump because they think he's
good for our democracy
and you democrats don't support
democracy very much at all
you support nine
elected lawyers nine rather appointed
lawyers on the supreme court
taking decisions away from the people
you support the doctor factories of the
world taking decisions
away from the people you support all
sorts of anti-democratic
institutions you support censorship from
big technology companies
you support woke corporations
undermining
the will of the people in georgia for
instance to beef up their their election
integrity laws
there's a great line i read from angelo
codevilla at the claremont institute
where he pointed out that whenever
democrats invoke the phrase our
democracy
they're referring to their oligarchy pay
attention to it every time they use it
our democracy this is
tammy duckworth here is criticizing
republican voters
for speaking to their republican
elected officials who are using their
own judgment
and channeling the will of the people
and tammy duckworth says this is a
threat to our democracy what are you
talking about that's the expression of
our democracy
this is such an empty line it's such an
empty line and look there are
plenty of criticisms of democracy plenty
of criticisms that our founding fathers
made and are the framers of our
constitution made you can read about
them in the federalist papers
so i'm not i'm not saying that i think
we need a i'm a democracy purist or no i
i
like constitutional government but if
you had to choose right now which party
in the united states is
the more pro-democracy party there's no
question that it's the republicans
democrats don't like our democracy they
are now
openly telling us that when they get
into positions of power
they are going to do their best to
undermine some of our basic
civil rights in our democracy for
instance
the right to keep and bear arms senator
cruz just
grilled joe biden's atf nominee
the bureau of alcohol tobacco and
firearms
three of my absolute favorite things
that come under heavy scrutiny from the
federal government
the atf nominee admitted he want he
wants to ban
the most popular rifle in america the
ar-15
is one of if not the most popular rifle
in america it's not a machine gun it's a
rifle
your public position is that you want to
ban ar-15s is that correct
senator uh thank you for the question
and
thank you for our visit yesterday and
offering me a dr pepper
it made me reminisce about my time in
central texas but now to your uh
question
uh with respect to the ar-15 on i
support uh
ban as as has been presented
in a senate bill and supported by the
president
the ar-15 is a gun i was issued on atf's
swat team and it's a particularly lethal
weapon
and regulating it as other particularly
lethal weapons
i have advocated for as
atf director if i'm confirmed i would
simply enforce the laws on the books and
right now
um there is no such ban on those guns
so you want to ban the most popular
rifle in america
you gotta love senator cruz here this
guy
is so good at being a senator he i don't
just say it
because we host the show together i
don't just say because he's a friend of
mine he's really good
the the biden atf nominee he's trying to
do that washington thing he's trying to
really you know present himself as
totally above board guy he's flattering
ted cruz he's
creating rapport he says so hey hey atf
nominee you you want to ban the most
popular rifle in america he goes
senator i just want to begin thank you
for thanks for giving me that diet coke
or whatever dr pepper oh yeah that
brought me back that doctor i love dr
pepper
yep that's great i had a great time with
you yesterday senator
so yeah you know i i look i think i
would i would want to ban the gun but
you know look there'd be laws and this
and that
cruz just doesn't even move he just goes
yeah okay so
you want to ban the most popular gun in
america is that right
well uh oh yeah yes cash can't get
around that
he does and credit to this atf nominee
i'm sure he couldn't hide it i'm sure
there were public statements to this
effect
but he comes out and he says yeah i do i
want to ban
the most popular rifle in america
that cuts to the heart of our democracy
that cuts
to the heart of our civil rights it's
one of the most important civil rights
in our country
the ability to keep and bear arms and
we're not even talking about some fully
automatic weapon we're not talking about
pistols which are used in a whole lot of
crime
we're talking about rifles which are
used in relatively very few crimes
specifically that ar-15 they want to get
rid of it speaking of violence
a biden campaign official is telling
jews to stop wearing yarmulkes
now the biden campaign official is
jewish himself he was the
i think he's jewish he was the lead
jewish outreach
guy for the biden harris campaign he
tweeted out it pains me to say this
but if you fear for your physical safety
take off your kippah
and hide your magen david i don't know
if i'm pronouncing that correctly
that's the star of david i suppose
obviously if you can
ask your rabbi first this is the wrong
answer
this is this is sad that he would say
this
because there is increased violence
against jews it's not like there are
pogroms or anything going on right now
but there is increased violence from
pro-palestinian people
that's true it's not from not from
conservative
christian republicans it's from
pro-palestinian people who i suspect
side with the left
and what this guy is saying is hey hide
your religion hide who you are hide your
identity
hide your religion that's the wrong idea
i hear this a lot
outside of the explicitly religious
realm in the political realm people will
sometimes say hey college kids
hide the fact that you're a conservative
just hide it just keep your head down
then someday in the future you can have
integrity wrong answer guys
courage is a virtue it's not just a
virtue it's the prerequisite
for all the other virtues if you don't
have courage you're not going to have
all any of the other virtues because
you're not going to be able to exercise
them not surprised to see this coming
from a biden flag
but really dispiriting to see really
awful awful thing to be telling people
then speaking of jewish guys ben is
going to be talking about the woke quest
to destroy the military from within this
is very bad stuff ben will have a lot of
courage on this show unlike what we're
seeing from the bidenflax so make sure
you check out
ben's show today also sign up as a daily
wire member with code vip
get 20 off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip to the daily wire studios
to see candace live this deal ends on
memorial day so don't wait another
minute you're not going to
get another chance so do not sleep on it
go enter now to win two vip tickets to
canvas
get the canvas vip pass at dailywear.com
subscribe
using code vip for 20 off we'll be right
back with a lot more
the pro-palestine stuff is really
popular right now
it's popular on the left increasingly so
and in some corners of the right it's
increasingly popular and i sort of get
why
it's becoming a little more popular on
the right i think it's because people
are reacting to
what they feel is an extremist position
that we've seen for the past couple
years a couple of decades rather we were
talking about this a little bit on the
backstage show last night for the past
couple of decades we've been told israel
is america's greatest ally
at least in republican circles you're
the greatest ally ever and
you have to always support israel all
the time and if not you're
a no good dirty rotten unpatriotic
american
i'm being only slightly hyperbolic and
some people are looking at and saying
well i don't know i don't owe
an allegiance to a foreign country that
that's not doesn't constitute my
patriotism in the united states
and so they'll react against that sort
of thing but
to me it's similar to when people have
been told their whole lives
if you're a white guy you need to feel
ashamed and
terrible because men are awful and white
people are terrible
and so you can react in this sort of
juvenile way and say actually
black people are terrible actually women
are terrible you know you react in a
kind of performative
racist or misogynistic or whatever sort
of way but that's not the answer right
the
the appropriate answer is to use your
common sense i guess that's kind of the
theme of the show today isn't it
use your common sense and say no white
people aren't terrible at all white
people are perfectly fine
actually this was an explicit question
that a leftist
uh commentator brought up it was people
are knocking him for the question we'll
get to that in just a second because
that
the question i think is important for
people to consider right now but the the
appropriate
answer i think is to say no what why
people are perfectly fine no men i think
are perfectly fine i think they have
some virtues actually believe it or not
so this is how i look at the
pro-palestine stuff susan sarandon
who's a left-wing far-left actress
she tweeted out i stand with the
palestinian people fighting against the
apartheid government and
of netanyahu and pray for the israeli
people that they too will enjoy peace
i also support bella hadid i don't even
know who that is for having bravery to
stand in solidarity with her people
that can be lonely
here's a good rule of thumb if you don't
know all the nuances of say the
israel-palestinian conflict
which very few people understand the
nuances because the conflict goes back a
very long time
there are rules of thumb that we follow
prudence just prejudice i know prejudice
is a bad word in recent decades
but we all need prejudice to form
or to just to get through the world what
is a prejudice a prejudice is
a not totally rationally abstractly
formed opinion
that we just sort of receive it involves
gut instinct it involves
the received opinion of our forebears
and that's
how we get through the world there are
unjust prejudices but there are just
prejudices too
here's a just prejudice if aoc ilhan
omar
nancy pelosi susan sarandon bernie
sanders
if all these guys are uniformly on one
side of a political issue
probably you should be on the other side
i'm not saying 100
of the time but most of the time that's
just common sense
a lot of this a lot of the the
israel-palestine issue comes down
to race hustling okay i think a lot of
it comes down to
this modern unjust prejudice that
brown people good white people bad i
think we're taught that i think people
are taught that in schools they're
taught to abolish whiteness
their classes at universities about
abolishing whiteness
you hear this sort of stuff in
workplaces and it's just
wrong and stupid so mark lamont hill
who is a leftist commentator he's a
black guy he used to go
on fox news sometimes actually i think
mark lamontiel i guess now has his own
show and he was was interviewing
christopher ruffo who's doing
excellent work at city journal exposing
critical race theory
which is one of the derivations of
critical theory which is one of the main
topics in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order
thank you so much everybody who has
pre-ordered apparently the pre-sales
are going gangbusters they're going to
have to print up more books
so we're very excited about all of that
you can get a signed first edition copy
over premiere collectibles
so mark lamont hill is interviewing
christopher ruffo and he asks the
question if
whiteness is not always a bad thing
what do you like about being white and
if i were to say to you right now
christopher what do you like about being
white what would you say
i don't know i again again it's such an
amorphous term it's like a census term
or a
but can you can you indulge me in
indulge me for once
just we're running out of time indulge
me for a minute i understand you see it
as as all these things but
you surely recognize that the world sees
you as white you know the world reads
you as white
and if you were to ask me some things i
like about being black i could talk
about cultural norms i could talk about
tradition i could talk about
the kind of commonalities i feel around
the diaspora if i were to ask you what
particularly if you're saying whiteness
is a thing that is being constructed as
negative and shouldn't be
name name something positive that you
like about being white
well sure i i you know i'll i'll answer
with a with a thing they're
you're telling me you're making
strongmen about things that are ascribed
to whiteness that you think are
wrongfully ascribed to whiteness i'm
saying if whiteness isn't a negative
thing
and there's something that you actually
and that whiteness actually shouldn't be
constructed as all negative
name something positive about being that
you believe is positive about being
white
again i don't buy into the framework
that the world can be reduced into these
metaphysical categories of whiteness and
blackness
oh man this is a good question people
are
attacking mark lamont hill for asking
this question but it's a brilliant
question
not because it stumps chris ruffo
actually the fact that chris ruffo can't
answer the question
is the same reason why mark lamont hill
did answer the question
and it's just a fact of our culture now
you are not allowed to say
that there is anything good about being
white
and likewise you're not really allowed
to say that there's anything bad about
being black
you're not allowed to say any that
there's anything about particularly good
about white
culture you're not even really allowed
to say that there is a white culture
people who attack
white people are allowed to say there's
a white culture but people who are white
are not allowed to acknowledge that
there is any such thing as a white
culture
and it's not just a trick question
because one of the tr
the trick that mark lamont hill could
have thrown on chris ruffo here
is he could have said what's good about
being white you're you're saying
whiteness is not purely negative
okay so what's good about being white
and then chris ruffo says i don't know
whatever you know
lobster rolls or something and and mark
lamont hill could have said how dare you
you racist
there's being or any race is neither
good nor bad
it's just you're racist you think but
mark does not say that he says
look i'm black i think there's some good
things about being black
this is some cultural norms some
commonalities he's using really vague
terms you'll notice
but he says yeah i think there are good
things about being black specifically
about being black so
what are some good things about being
white but you're not allowed to answer
that
you're not allowed to answer that but i
guess i guess
if you're allowed to say it about every
other race and i guess i guess
i guess you should be allowed to say it
about being white right chris chris's
impulse is to say there's no such thing
as white people but mark lamont hill is
saying no there is and
i'm your skin looks different than my
skin
whether it's a social construct or it's
a biological essential characteristic
there is such a thing as white people so
you tell me i'm telling you that there
is such a thing as white people and it's
totally negative
so you tell me there's something
positive and i don't i guess if i had to
answer the question what would i say
what is what is good about being white
uh
a lower risk of sickle cell anemia
that's pretty good
right i get are we not allowed to say
that's a good thing to be at a lower
risk of
sickle cell anemia beyond that i don't
know um
some history i don't know there's some
one does take pride in history
not pride in the sense of you know
excessive love of one's own excellence
not pride you know that
that goeth before destruction and a
haughty spirit before to fall but one
does take
some satisfaction in the history of
one's community this is true
actually mark lamont hill sort of
alludes to it himself so sure yeah i
think that's true
that's right conservatives i think
ignore that or deny that at their own
peril we're conservatives obviously we
like some things about history
what else i like sockless loafers is
that part of white culture i get kind of
yeah i guess so
i like um what else do i like like the
stiff upper lip
you know in english culture this is not
true of
all white white cultures i guess you'd
have to get a little more specific
the italians are not exactly known for
the stiff upper lip they're a little
more emotive
but the brits are known for this
they don't make a big show of their
emotions all the time they're not always
whining and screaming unless they're
prince hairy
they push things down a little bit and
just go on and have a little manly
courage that's good
is that good am i going to get cancelled
for answering mark lamont hill's
question
i know that that he's using this as a
kind of
rhetorical tactic but it actually shows
you something very important
which is everybody else
has a racial consciousness and this is
encouraged except for white people
and there's a trick even to this i mean
so there was a pew research
survey that measured racial
consciousness
measured it among black people hispanics
asians and whites
every one of those three groups said
that their race the first three groups
said that their race was somewhat or
very important to their sense of
identity
among black people it was quite high and
it was over 70 percent and among
hispanics and asians it was over 50
do you know what the number was for
white people 15
1-5 white people have basically
no racial identity fine by me i i guess
i count myself in that group of white
people who don't
think about race very much at all
there's a reason for this
a practical reason which is in countries
where you're the majority
you're you're just not going to be that
aware of race so it was perfect
perfectly natural i think if i were
walking around tibet
i think i'd probably be more aware of my
race than if i were walking around
kansas city however there's another
reason here which is that
anti-racism is an idea that only exists
in white countries if there's no
anti-racism in china okay there's no
anti-racism
in i don't know namibia or
right there's no anti-racism in
saudi arabia
anti-racism the idea that there are more
important things in life
and race actually doesn't really matter
that much at all in politics
that is a western idea and it comes from
countries that
at least historically are white
countries so that's
part of the trick here as well you're
not allowed to say it but see how
unstable that is
see how how many contradictions there
are see how uncomfortable that quest
line of questioning was because what
mark lamont hill is showing
is that in our new racial caste system
there is
one set of rules for non-white people
and there's another set of rules for
white people
it's this this racial politics is a
totally rigged
game and
it's very effective for the radical life
this is why the radical left is focused
very much on on racial politics
nicole hannah jones is a liar she's one
of the most famous
liars in the country she's the person
behind the 1619 project
at the new york times the central thesis
of which is a lie
the lie that the american revolution was
fought to preserve slavery it's just not
true
she won the pulitzer prize for it she
won the macarthur genius grant for it
but it's just not true and the new york
times even had to admit it they had to
correct the thesis the whole thing fell
apart doesn't matter it's being taught
in schools because the new york times
spent millions of dollars to promote the
thing
so nicole hannah jones who is
as far as i can tell not particularly
intelligent she doesn't have very many
scholarly credentials she's winning a
lot of plaudits
and awards from the popular culture but
she's no scholar
she's a hack activist journalist well
she was teaching at the university of
north carolina at chapel hill
she was up for tenure and the board of
trustees denied her tenure of course
the woman doesn't even have a phd i'm
not one for credentialism but it is very
strange
for tenured professors not to have phds
very very unusual
she's just not fit for the job even if
she did have a phd she wouldn't be fit
for the job but she certainly doesn't
now
so they denied her tenure this created a
big
race hustling political problem for unc
now she's up for tenure again
she is uh she was denied tenure
according to the radicals because of
conservative groups
and conservatives on the board of
governors of the university
so i guess they're saying conservatives
are not allowed to have any influence
over this public university
so now 1619 alumni get it
wow a symbolism bought a one-page ad in
a local newspaper
saying what we are one 1 619 university
of north carolina alumni
outraged by the board of trustees
failure to approve a tenured
professorship
for unc alumna and founder of the 1619
project
nicole hannah jones we demand that the
board of trustees immediately revisit
this matter
grant tenure is recommended by the
appropriate faculty dean of provost
and restore the integrity of our
university
no university with integrity would allow
this woman to even speak there
the the fact that this is even being
discussed the fact that she's a graduate
raises questions about the integrity of
that university that they would allow
this woman to graduate with a degree in
at least one fake department
hannah nicole j no not anna nicole smith
nicole henderson calhoun jones tweets
out this fight is not about me we call
on
all people of conscience to decry this
growing wave of refresh repression and
to encourage a recommitment to the free
exchange of ideas
i know she tweeted that because it was
written about it in an article but i
didn't see it on twitter because you
know
you know what happened when i went to
look at her twitter she blocked me
nicole anna jones who says we need to
recommit to the free exchange of ideas
and restore integrity
she blocked me she doesn't believe in
the free exchange of ideas she's a liar
she should not be at any university
in our culture we are rewarding
bad faith actors we are rewarding liars
we are rewarding people and
giving them positions where they can
communicate their trash to the masses
and we are suppressing voices that speak
the truth
father james altman
father james altman catholic priest in
wisconsin
you might remember him because some of
his homilies
some of his uh videos went viral during
the election because he had the audacity
to defend catholic teaching against
the heresies of the radical woke left
and the the new pseudo-religion of the
radical woke left you remember him take
a listen
there are way too many people who don't
know the first thing
about almighty god father son and holy
spirit
so truth be told they do not love him
and so we can see in the many godless
politicians out there in the godless
educational system
in the godlessness of so many sheeples
they most definitely
are not serving him they are not
fulfilling their purpose in life
to know to love and to serve god oh
you're just being
political father altman is too
political politics has no place
in the catholic church baloney
pope benedict xvi said the church is not
a political power
it's not a party but it is at least it's
supposed to be
it is a moral power
therefore since politics
fundamentally should be a moral
enterprise the church in this
sense has something to say about
politics
therefore when politics and politicians
act in an immoral way
we most certainly do have the duty and
the obligation to speak up and speak up
about it
absolutely absolutely right was very
pleased to see
father altman's homilies and to see him
speaking out on important
moral matters this is what good
shepherds do so now he's being asked to
resign
by his bishop the bishop uh
william patrick callahan last friday
asked for uh father altman to resign for
allegedly being quote
divisive and ineffective because of his
controversial rhetoric
defending catholic teaching
now i i do not want to just
leap to the conclusion that
there's no issue here that's legitimate
that the bishop does not have the right
to request this resignation
father altman fortunately has hired a
cannon lawyer and is is fighting back in
appealing this up to the vatican
as well he should but the catholic
church is not a democracy
nor should it be a democracy it's just
not the way the body functions
the kingdom of heaven is not a democracy
either so i understand that
but all too often we have seen
bishops we have seen priests we've seen
members of the episcopacy
bowing down to the worldliness
of our politics
to radicals you know there was a move
there was a leak that the u.s council of
catholic bishops
would hold biden's feet to the fire on
his
scandal the scandal that he so openly
supports
abortion in contravention of the church
teachings among among other things by
the way
very important matters on marriage on
all these sorts of things
so we'll follow this story i hope that
father altman is permitted to speak
very often some of the greatest priests
some of the greatest saints of the
church
have faced a lot of pushback from their
bishops saint padre pio
among them uh saint john henry newman
had some scuffles with his bishop so
this is not
not uh unusual but uh it should raise
questions for people such as bishop
callahan
and and others who are attacking father
altman are they really on the right side
here
are you sure if you're siding with
radical leftists
over a priest who is defending orthodoxy
are you sure you're on the right side of
that sort of thing
people are very confused about things
that matter have you noticed that i
i have to address this i posted
something on
i didn't even post it i gave a speech
for the young americas foundation they
posted a clip
where i pointed out that i was making
fun of asa hutchinson that governor of
arkansas
when asa hutchinson invoked bill buckley
and ronald reagan to defend castrating
kids
and i said you know there are more
important things in life
than occupational licensing reform he
said
if you're a conservative party that
won't defend children against the
predations of perverts who are trying to
castrate them
you're not conserving very much you know
i'm all for tax cuts but there's more
important things in life so i posted
this
and a bunch of squishes jumped on it
and said oh my gosh are you crazy
there's
occupational licensing reform is the
most important thing in the world
i'm not um not opposed to occupational
licensing reform i'm not opposed to tax
cuts
but there are more important things in
life and i think a lot of people the
kind of
elite sort of fashionable conservatives
who pretend that all they really care
about is
something like occupational licensing
reform that that's the only thing that
matters
they're really just trying to be liked
by the left what they're really saying
is no you know i just care about these
really
specific economic issues of
of tweaking ways that the financial
regulations work
it's it's a way of avoiding difficult
problems
it's a way of saying look i just want
you leftists to be able to do whatever
you want you
even more so actually i want to expand
the things that you can do
but that's just not enough an effective
conservative movement needs to tell
people
no can't just tell people yes yes yes
got to tell people no it's gonna say no
you can't kill the baby no you can't
castrate the kid no a little boy can't
become a little girl
no i'm sorry i know that's not gonna
make me popular i know i'm gonna get
mean tweets
but there are more important things in
life than avoiding mean
tweets that's just the way
it is i think a lot of the political
battle right now
on the on the right you know there's the
liz cheney crew
there's the crew that pretends that tax
cuts are just the only thing that ever
matters in politics
there's the crew that's willing to
engage in the social issues
a lot of the difference there is between
are you going to go along to get along
with this increasingly insane liberal
regime
or are you going to fight back and
you're going to be called all sorts of
names and racist and sexist and all
sorts of stuff
as someone actually when they saw this
clip that i posted
pointing out that it's bad to castrate
kids they said you're just
ginning up the culture war you're you're
pushing a moral panic
as if to say hey stop panicking and let
us trans the kids
but you see this on other issues stop
panicking and let us kill the babies
stop panicking and let us sell out our
national sovereignty to foreign nations
like china
no no we're not going to do that but
we'll give you tax cuts
uh no still no but but if we
if we don't just go along with
everything the left might
say mean things to us yes they might get
over it courage
is the prerequisite of all the other
virtues the only way that we're going to
defend anything that even slightly
resembles our
true democracy i'm michael knowles the
michael miller show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show joe biden proposes a
six trillion dollar budget that would
sink the economy and raise the national
debt
to record levels plus the biden white
house is pushing wokeness in america's
military industrial complex and
taking china's word for it on the
origins of coven 19. so everything's
going great that's today on the bench
bureau should i give it a listen
you